[Music]
all right people
it is debate night in america
and if you're watching this you survived
that
whatever that was that we just watched
that was weird
um that was bizarre that was messy
and i don't think a lot of good came out
of it no matter who you like
i'm dave rubin i'm here with whiskey and
i
finally got to use if if nothing else
positive came out of this evening i've
had these star wars stormtrooper head
uh ice you know ice makers
basically can you see that there that is
a stormtrooper's head
and i've got whiskey
and i've got hardcore political analysis
for you people
we've got about eight clips from the
evening i'll give you some
some general thoughts on uh on what that
was like i actually thought i didn't
realize
until about 10 minutes ago i thought
that thing was going another half
hour it went by kind of quick but it
felt like a
like a slog there wasn't there wasn't a
lot of
great moments neither one of them really
went on a run
uh it was it was a little it was a
little bizarre so here's what i'm gonna
do i'm going to do what i always try to
do
sometimes i do it better than other
times i'm going to really try to be
as as non-partisan as possible here but
i will put my cards on the table
but it's very obvious if any of you have
been watching this that i am
much more in line with the way
conservatives
are thinking these days and the way
trump has been thinking these days
than i am with the democrats and
certainly biden so i'm just putting that
out there and you can
you can sort of hold that you can put
that in your pocket
as you listen to me analyze this stuff
and i would just say one other thing if
you're kind of new to what i do
uh i have been a democrat basically
my entire life from as early as i
remember i was thinking about this today
actually this part got cut out of my
book
but when i got into politics it was
eighth grade around 1988
and it was when michael dukakis was
running against george h.w bush the
first bush
and we did a mock trial in my class and
i was one of the campaign managers
for michael dukakis and i thought he was
the good guy the liberal and bush was
the scary republican
who wanted war and money for old people
and the whole thing so as long as i've
been
in in into politics and i i went i was a
poli sci major in college a lot of i've
always been a lefty okay you know all
that stuff about me
uh let's talk about what happened
tonight now first off
you know as i said in the direct message
this morning it's like
most people at this point you probably
know who you're voting for you probably
know it maybe you haven't like
fully calcified the thought in your
brain but you just have an
inkling of going if you're not there yet
you just have this inkling like most
likely i'm going that way so the
question really in all of these debates
and in everything that happens over the
next five six weeks
is what how many people are in that
sliver of people who don't know what
they're gonna do
and they're gonna vote there may be a
whole hell of a lot of people who don't
know what they're gonna do but only a
certain amount of them are gonna vote
right so
whatever that number is that's what this
thing is really about and then can both
sides get the base
that does know what it's who who they're
going to vote for can they get them to
get out there
and vote so that's what this is really
about now first off i said it this
morning
and i think uh i was proven correct that
really all biden had to do was show up
and not make any mistakes
and although he was extremely rude and
we'll get to some of that stuff and you
know he called trump racist of course
and told him to shut up and you're the
worst president of history
and he had like a couple of those like
sort of anger moments
he didn't lose his train of thought
terribly he didn't get
mumbly fumbly he didn't have major
uh errors in in sentences he had one or
two things that he flubbed some things
at one point he
sort of implied that he was against
lockdowns but he's definitely been four
locked i was like some of that stuff
you know he lied about a bunch of stuff
you know this this hunter biden thing i
mean i just tweeted out an article about
it it does
appear that the moscow mayor's wife gave
hunter biden 3.5 million dollars
um you know like there was like stuff
like that which he knows he can get away
with because the media won't fact-check
him you know there's also stuff like
um you know the very fine people line
that they keep saying about trump with
charlottesville biden tonight said it
again
that's why he got into the race because
trump said there are very
fine people on both sides implying that
there are white supremacists and they're
fine people and then there's everyone
else and they're fine people
and this has been debunked a bajillion
times you will never
see this on mainstream media i did send
a tweet about it do we have that tweet
up there i know we have a bunch of video
i don't know if we grab that tweet um
no i don't think we grabbed that tweet
but i okay i did i did tweet about it
with a link to an actual article
that shows that trump did not just say
there are very fine people on both sides
what he was talking about was the statue
debate and whether you should take down
a robert e lee statue
he said i don't have the exact quote in
front of me but he said michael you
could pull it up actually that that
tweet that i had on the
the trump the trump line in
charlottesville uh in effect he said
uh i condemn the white supremacists and
the neo-nazis but michael will give me
the tweet in just a second or i can pull
it up on my phone and just oh wait i
think i got it here
yeah so the the quote was
uh the exact quote related to very fine
people
trump said i'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and white nationalists because
they should be condemned totally
so when people say he said very fine
people he's removing
the people that he condemned but of
course you're not going to see that on
abc i guarantee you ain't going to see
that on cnn tonight
and everywhere else so so look biden did
some of those moves
but he kept you know i was about to say
he kept his cool it's not that he kept
his cool his head didn't explode and and
the expectations i think were so low
that that's all he had to do his head
didn't explode
he's he reminded people a little bit
of what an old politician is which by
the way trump had some good moments on
that when he kept
the best line that trump had i think was
i've done more in 47 months than you did
in 47 years
i mean trump if if biden actually can
keep going here
well then trump's move has to be you
never accomplished anything any of the
things you're complaining about now
you never accomplished in all your years
so why would you be the guy that could
do it now
he also got biden to say he's not for
the for the green new deal and a couple
other things
so that that's some stuff on bite and
there was some good there was some anger
there was some dishonest stuff okay
trump i think
was basically okay but he was very jumpy
right out of the gate
like i think he was trying to go for the
knockout punch right off the top so he
was very combative with chris wallace
and we know this is this is what he does
right like this is part of
his tactic i don't think this was
something that was happening by mistake
but you know he gets into it with the
moderator he gets into it with the other
guy
you know he never insulted biden the way
biden
insulted him right you know when biden
calls him racist it's like this
this is meaningless but like they were
talking about critical race theory which
by the way
you know chris wallace and this is one
look i know what it's like to be an
interviewer and i've i've hosted some
debates but
but never a presidential debate and and
with such combative people although
i did do that candace owens blair white
thing that was uh pretty nutty
uh some of you remember that save dave
um
but what chris wallace does is he asks
questions that he sort of knows or not
real questions so when he asks the
question about charlottesville and very
fine people
you you can't tell me that chris wallace
doesn't know
that that is not true that the premise
of the question is not true
or a minute later not a minute later but
right around there when they moved it
over to critical race theory
um and he's trying to to pose the
question chris wallace
pose the question as if it's anti-racism
training so
everyone's against anti-racism except
critical race theory is racism
so now trump can either spend his time
trying to explain that
or he can just sort of go ahead and
steamroll and his his
method is to go ahead and steamroll so i
think
no if you want the bumper sticker on
this whole thing i
i don't think there was any major winner
i don't think trump walks out of this
thing going
wow i just mopped up and you know people
saw that that biden cognitively can't do
it
and that he's a puppet to the left like
i don't think that stuff really
landed and i don't think anyone walked
away and said that
that biden really won this thing i think
the biden people and the mainstream
media if you've got
cnn or any of those channels on now i'm
sure they're all saying that that biden
won and trump was angry and blah blah
although biden was really the angry one
like someone should do a super cut if
you guys want to
uh tweet it at me i'll retweet it if
someone could do a supercut of all the
insults that biden through trump's way
and he's supposed to be you know and he
keeps saying you know you're not
presidential and then it's like you're
dumb
you're a racist you know you're an idiot
you know to that effect
um i think the biden people internally
right now are breathing a major sigh of
relief
like i don't think they thought that he
would be able to be up there and not
have
any major gaffes and not completely lose
himself and the rest of it
so i don't know what that is like they
rested this guy maybe that really is
what it is look
there were 11 days this month as i said
this morning
where the biden campaign put a lid on
his campaign so he had no
public speaking after about 10 am 11
times this
month so was the guy well rested
did he finally get his head on straight
i don't know
i don't know uh but but he did not
implode and i think that
that sort of is a win for him just that
in and of itself so let's go to a couple
clips here
as i said before there were there were
no like major knockout
moments there were no moments that
everyone online was like that was it
like you know like we can really call a
clean clean cut winner
by the way if you're watching any other
analysis right now and they're telling
you there was absolutely a clean cut
winner like
like no doubt and and that it moved
votes that's what it really is that it
moved votes
not just that your guy feels good about
it right so whether if you love trump or
you love biden right now
it's like i don't think you can honestly
say that your guy knocked it out of the
park
at the moment you could we could all
disagree on okay this guy did a little
better or something like that
but i don't think you can say anyone
knocked it out of the park so uh let's
go to this first clip this is clip
number one this is biden refusing to
answer
whether he will pack the courts if he
becomes president
so my question to you is you have
refused in the past to talk about it
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know he doesn't we're
senators i'm not going to answer the
question
okay so vote now you're right joe people
should vote and you're not going to
believe this one and this is where it's
going to get tough for you joe
they did vote they did vote for this
senate they did vote for this president
and trump trump did have a good line on
this
when he he loosely quoted ruth bader
ginsburg who said
that these people are voted in for their
term the president is not voted in for
three years or three years and six
months
the president's voted in for four years
so he's supposed to do his job
for four years if you're a contractor
and you're doing a job you don't just
chop off the time at the end because
you're close to being at the end so that
senate is supposed to do their job
and the president supposed to do their
job it's fairly obvious that what biden
was doing here
um was well hey it's the political trick
that both sides play right if somebody's
if an incumbent is getting to the end
and there's an election
uh you don't want him to be able to
choose the supreme court nominee the
republicans did this with obama right
merrick garland we we know this
uh but trump also i thought had an
effective line on that which was well
they didn't have the senate then so i've
got the senate this is what we're gonna
do that's just real
politic i think biden's problem right
there
was that the truth is that he in
in effect he is
he's losing his own base there because
his base
is saying to him we're gonna pack the
courts so he whether he thinks it's
right or not he can't say we're not
going to pack the courts because he's
out he's out there
with all of his rabid base saying we're
going to do it we're going to pack the
courts we're going to get rid of the
electoral college
it's that we're going to ruin all the
norms so that was that was one thing
um let's let's go to clip number two uh
this well here's trump and the phone
well he wants to shut down this country
oh and i want to keep it open and we did
it again
wait a minute let me shut you down for a
second joe just for one second
he wants to shut down the country i'm
going to shut you down i mean that that
that's a pretty good line
um i think this was one of those ones
where because they were talking over
each other it's like
there there's a there's a real
difference there like this is a big one
right the coven situation and the
lockdowns this is a big one
and i think they both really had an
opportunity
to to kind of win some points here trump
saying i want to open things up and
really
making that mark i think that's that's
an effective mark
um and he did say leaving it up to the
states and blah blah blah but that his
his ideal it seemed like would be to
open up the country and
biden has been implying i think it was
just in the last day or two
uh this thing about that there would be
a national uh
lockdown into into 2021 something to
that effect
um so you know this is again one of
those ones it was just it was just a
cheap little line
let's move past that one let's go to
trump and the economy
so we built the greatest economy in
history we closed it down because of the
china plague when the plague came in we
closed it down which was very hard
psychologically to do he didn't think we
should close it down and he was wrong
and again two million people would be
dead now instead of
still 204 000 people is too much one
person is too much
should have never happened from china
but what happened is
we closed it down and now we're
reopening and we're doing record
business
we had 10.4 million people in a
four-month period that we've
put back into the workforce that's a
record the likes of which nobody's ever
seen before
and he won yeah so this started as you
know about covid
and when to shut down things and trump
saying this line about if we didn't do
it this way
you know two million people would have
died instead of 200 000 people and i
thought his line on
uh you know with one person dying is too
many that that is the right sentiment
right
you know a lot of this is insider
baseball and it's uh you know hindsight
is 2020. you can always attack the guy
who's in charge now
and i would have done this differently
and the lockdown here and you know let's
not forget like when trump
was trying to get travel from china stop
people were calling him xenophobic and
racist and all the usual
all the usual stuff as far as the
economic recovery i mean we're still
in it right now so i don't think either
one of them really came off
in this moment looking looking
particularly
particularly good i mean the point is
what what answers
do you have the economy is coming back a
bit
but if you keep hampering the economy
with a lockdown and then you don't
honestly tell us what's going on with
kovid
it's like well the economy really can't
get going fully
and i don't think it's too much of a
conspiracy to think that democratic
governors want to keep states locked
down so the economy sucks and people
don't know where to put that anger so
they just they put it on trump they put
it on the president like that does that
doesn't strike me as a conspiracy theory
that
just strikes me that's real politic like
politics is
is messy and dirty and and i think
people actually end up doing
doing stuff like that uh let's go a
little bit more on the on the lockdowns
because trump went in on this idea of
the of the democratic lockdowns as long
as i'm talking about this
that's clip four he will shut it down
again
he will destroy this country you know a
lot of people between drugs
and alcohol and depression when you
start shutting it down you take a look
at what's happening at some of your
democrat-run states where they have
these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came out last week you saw that
oh we're going to open up on november
9th why november 9th because it's after
the election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them close they're hurting people
people know what to do they can social
distance they can wash their hands they
can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but
they've got to open these states up
when you look at north carolina when you
look and these governors are under siege
pennsylvania michigan and a couple of
others
you gotta open these states up it's not
fair you're talking about almost
it's like being in prison and you look
at what's going on with divorce
look at what's going on with alcoholism
and drugs it's a very very sad thing
and he'll close down the whole country
this guy will close down the whole
country
and destroy our country our country is
coming back incredibly well
setting records as it does it we don't
need somebody to come in and say let's
shut it down
all right so i actually thought that was
a pretty solid moment to loosely quote
mary said they're
they're hurting people people know what
to do people know about social
distancing people
know about wearing masks but we got to
let them live and i thought that was
probably his most human moment too when
he talked about
depression and alcoholism and people
getting divorced and all of that stuff
you know that's not the stuff
that we're really good about talking
about at
at a national level and politicians
really aren't good talking about it
they love spouting numbers 200 million
this 200 000 that
this the gdp went up you know your your
401k went down there that that's the
type of stuff and
we all kind of get lost in these numbers
as if it's just about numbers
but there is a a human element to this
and i think that was probably
trump's best moment because as i said he
was a little jumpy all night
but he was he was human there and i
think he was trying to say that
it's not all policy right it's not all
that we can just come up with magical
policies to make you feel better what we
can do
is hopefully uh open things up so you
can make some decisions in your life and
even that what lays beneath
that obviously is that that is not
perfect because not everyone's going to
make the right decisions and
people could get sick and and all of
that but i think trump was was doing
something kind of human there and when
he
when he turned to biden and he said you
know this thing about
uh you know he's going to keep the
country locked down it's like that
is that is seemingly what biden will do
unless magically if biden gets uh
gets voted in suddenly covet goes away
which would be uh
which would really be something um yeah
the the covet thing that that sort of
sits there with all this is sort of
interesting because we've been told
right here let me have some whiskey
before i get to this one
better with the star wars helmet um with
the stormtrooper helmet
um you know it's interesting because
it's covid was how much of the
the debate here was maybe i don't know
maybe 20
something like that maybe 15 and it's
like if we are in the
biggest worldwide pandemic of
modern times and and people are dying
left and right and we've shut down the
economy and everyone
is hurting and all those things you'd
think that the whole debate the whole
debate would have been about that
but in a certain way it's just another
piece
of the puzzle here and i think that's
just like another one of the reasons
that people have trouble
focusing on actually what's important
and i think what trump probably should
be doing
more is is saying to people and i think
he would got to this a little bit is
we can't solve all of your problems that
would that would kind of be on
be the honest thing to do um versus
biden
you know when he keeps he makes a point
of talking directly to the camera and
you this
and it's like you know and this is what
we want to help you we want to help you
it's for you
it's like i'm very leery of people that
just want to give me stuff because
they're so great you know what i mean i
don't think these guys
can can really give me a lot uh let's
let's move on
um because this is this was sort of
interesting i referenced
one of the quotes here uh this is clip
number seven
and uh this is when they got into to
race a little bit and there were some
weird moments here and
and at least one point where i think
trump dropped the ball and will probably
regret it
right you did a crime bill 1994
where you call them super predators
african-americans the super predators
and they've never forgotten it
they've never forgotten it jefferson no
sir it's his two minutes so you did that
and they call you
super predator and i'm letting people
out of jail now that
you have treated the african-american
population community you have treated
the black community
about as bad as anybody in this country
you did the 1999 and that's why
if you look at the polls i'm doing
better than any republican has done in a
long time
because they saw what you did you call
them super predators and you've called
them worse than that
because you look back at your testimony
over the years you've called them a lot
worse than that as far as the church is
concerned
and as far as the generals are concerned
we just got the support of 200
mil 250 military leaders and generals
total support law enforcement almost
every law enforcement
group in the united states i have
florida i have texas
i have ohio i have every
excuse me portland the sheriff just came
out today and he said i support
president trump i don't think you have
any law enforcement you can't even say
the word law enforcement because if you
say those words
you're going to lose all of your radical
left supporters and why
aren't you saying those words why don't
you say the words law enforcement
because
you know what if they called us in
portland we would put out that fire in a
half an hour but they won't do it
because they're run by radical left
democrats
if you look at chicago if you look at
any place you want to look seattle
they heard we were coming in the
following day and they put up their
hands and we got back seattle
minneapolis we got it back joe because
we believe in law and order but you
don't
the top 10 cities in just about the top
40 cities
are run by democrats in many cases
radical left and they've got you wrapped
around their finger joe
to a point where you don't want to say
anything about law and order
and i'll tell you what the people of
this country want and demand
law and order and you're afraid to even
say it
okay so that actually struck me as
trump's probably best run of the whole
thing because they were obviously
talking about what's on everyone's mind
which is riots and protests and burning
down of cities and
the attacks on law enforcement and
people being afraid
and more than anything else when i hear
now
of liberals or lefties that are going
i've just had it with the democratic
party i don't know what's going on here
or anything else
it's because of that it's because of
literally their own safety so i think
that was sort of
trump at his best tonight and he did
make an interesting point and i've been
hitting it for quite some time
that if seattle and portland and
minneapolis and these all democratic-run
cities that are that are on fire and
burning down
if they won't do anything then the feds
have to get involved and and he said it
very quickly so you'd have to sort of be
paying attention
to the to the story over the last couple
months to really know what he was saying
but his point was when we threatened to
send in the feds and when we did do some
stuff
things got cleaned up real quick right
and and that is
true chop in seattle is no more portland
has been largely cleaned up because of
the threat it
isn't because of mayor ted wheeler who
moved out of his apartment complex
because they got violent with him too
even though he's a far lefty so i think
that was probably trump's best moment
when i said before the clip that he had
his worst moment
it was couched around this when the
question was idiotically loaded
by chris uh by chris wallace this thing
about
um will trump will trump condemn white
supremacy now chris wallace knows
that trump has done this repeatedly he
knows even though he didn't say it
before as i mentioned in the
charlottesville thing he knows trump has
said it
then they got into an exchange where
biden wallace and trump were all talking
at the exact same time
and trump needed to just get in there
and say and he started saying it but he
never finished
he started saying something he fumbled
he turned to wallace he's fighting with
him biden was talking
and he needed to say without question i
i condemn white supremacy now i know
what a lot of you are thinking and
you're right
that this is it's a false question and
it's an unfair question and he's done it
before and everything else
the problem is that what you have to
understand is that while while you guys
who watch things online while you
see that the average person doesn't see
the truth of the charlottesville story
the other the average person doesn't see
him condemning these things
so in that moment where he didn't just
flat out say his
he should have he started doing it and
then you know he speaks in a sometimes
stilted way and then wallace and biden
got in
and he never actually said it he kept
saying well what do you want me to say
what do you want me to say i think his
implication was
i've said this before like what else do
you want me to say but i think that's
the
the line that the campaign is going to
look at and go okay we we dropped the
ball on that
and it's unfortunate because it's a
false question and i think that was sort
of what
trump was was talking about and then of
course within that
uh when they were getting into the whole
race thing was the whole
critical race theory thing and that's
where biden called
called trump racist also i mean that
just it just
doesn't work anymore like does anyone
really if you're watching this right now
on your huge biden supporter
really i'm really curious about this
like do you really think that what
motivates
trump is racism that what he wants to do
is keep people down based on their race
even though at his state of the union
this past year
he was talking about all-time low black
unemployment and while he did it the
congressional black caucus
and all of the democrats sat there like
this like that would be the type of
thing that you'd all be applauding right
like in a in a sane world um so i just
don't i don't think those arguments work
anymore just saying oh you're racist
you're racist um i just don't think it
works
but but as i said at the beginning of
this one of the the key issues here
is that if you're a democrat and and
this is i think trump's sort of greatest
gift trump understands
that it's not just democrats versus
republicans it's democrats and the media
versus republicans
so biden can can lie about some of the
things that i've i've
brought up here but most importantly the
charlottesville thing
and he knows that the lie will just
continue because the mainstream media
won't touch it now thankfully because of
alternative media
you guys are able to see it um but if
trump lies about anything and i think he
was actually
pretty solid like it didn't
i'm sure i'll be corrected if i'm wrong
but it didn't strike me that he threw up
any like
major whoppers up there tonight uh you
know i'm sure there'll be things on
you know numbers related to the economic
recovery or this or that
right like fudging of numbers and they
all kind of fudge numbers
um but anyway uh one of the other lines
i want to show one more clip
and then uh analyze it a little bit
this this was the moment when um
biden said that antifa is an idea
not an organization now antifa which
coordinates on twitter which we know is
an
actual organization of people that is
quite well funded
and it is an actual group of people who
are out there
to organize to burn down cities or just
do
whatever the hell it is they want uh i
have been to plenty events
that have been protested by antifa so
they're not an idea if they were just an
idea i would go to my events they would
be successful
and i would hear about an idea you know
there's this idea from these people
called antifa
and they uh have these feelings about
this or that well
they actually do show up to events uh
this is an event that i did last year
i'm sure some of you have seen this clip
this thing went absolutely viral i did
an event up
in in canada we were in i believe we
were in hamilton
canada canada and i did an event a free
speech event
which i did it with maxine bernier from
the people's party of canada he's
basically a libertarian up there we had
muslims and jews and christians and
straight people and gay people and black
people and white people and everybody on
stage and we had
we had a great time but antifa was out
there protesting they were throwing
stuff at us as we went in somebody
knocked a little coffee on my shirt
um you know if you're being protested
this goes for everybody
uh because it'll come to you one day if
you're ever being protesting you have to
get into a building don't hold a hot
open coffee with you it's just not a
great idea
anyway uh let's just throw to this video
of this woman trying to get to the event
that i was talking about and remember
joe biden said that antifa is an idea
not an organization
oh
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna have to drink
for that one
cheers grammy um okay so it turns out
that that
that elderly woman who was coming to an
event that all we talked about was free
speech
all we talked about was free speech the
opening of that event
that was all about free speech was by
a muslim professor an immigrant to
canada talking about how wonderful the
western world is and everything else i
mean
the idea that anything racist there
happened is just absolutely ridiculous
but this woman's being called a nazi
this woman in her
in dozens of other stories of speaking
over the last couple years
and having to deal with that and it's
not just me and it's not just ben
shapiro and jordan peterson and all the
people who have been threatened with
violence and the rest of it by antifa so
this is not an idea
and why is it joe biden why i mean
explain to me why unless you're afraid
to inflame your base and say antifa
you're bad
antifa antifa however you want to say it
antifa
you are bad guys you cannot take over
roads you cannot violently
uh take over buildings and burn things
down why can't you just say that because
so much of the base
is mixed up in that that he can't say it
and that's
trump really was hitting on that with
the law and order stuff right and you
you don't want to talk about law and
order you don't want to talk about law
enforcement
so that i think trump did a nice job
with but but biden is going to have
i hope that he'll continue to get pushed
on this antifa they are not the good
guys
just yesterday here in l.a
at a place that on a sunset boulevard
famous sunset boulevard that everyone
knows sunset boulevard right
they anti-fun blm just these groups and
and partly they're amorphous by design
so you can say they're an idea not an
organization you don't know exactly
who's there
it's not like they're walking around
with laminated cards hi i'm a member of
antifa
um so what did they do they just
literally just shut down
sunset boulevard right at the laugh
factory right over there there's a great
there's a great old school deli there
and i used to get my hair cut on that
corner and they just decided to shut
down the street now
you may like whatever it is that they're
about you may love
radical marxism and crazy communism and
all the bananas lefty stuff
but you can't vote it in then i you know
vote in your communism your geniuses but
you can't just take over streets so when
biden says it's an idea like that's the
worst
sort of pandering but but i think what's
happened here is it'll backfire on him
because
people can see the videos and this is
also why why the big tech thing is so
important right now because
big tech and youtube and twitter and
facebook these are the these are the
ways that we can communicate with each
other so if they're messing with us with
algorithms and shadow bands and the rest
of it well then eventually we won't be
able to see
the counter narrative so sort of what
you're seeing here
uh and and i think maybe we'll be done
with the clips and i'll just kind of
talk to you about sort of
philosophically sort of what we're
seeing
is it's very obvious to me that when you
watch that debate tonight
um even if you like one of the two guys
that we are sort of
at the end of a certain something
doesn't it feel like
like watching two guys you know
in their 70s argue about the way the
world was and who's better
and the the insults and the way that
it's not
really a debate like i would have rather
put the two of the guys on stage
i don't even know that you need a
moderate moderator get to it guys you
got an hour and a half
talk it out like you know let's do some
old school
you know lincoln douglas stuff um but it
does
seem like we're we're getting to the end
i think that
that what 2020 will mark in many ways
will be the last
year of this sort of conventional
politics stuff at the presidential level
like it's not going to just happen
overnight
but i think we are getting to the place
that we will
start having new school candidates
people who will talk differently and
think differently
and i think there will be a way that
they won't be so
part of the system because even trump
who's against the system is
you know he's a billionaire who's in the
system like it just felt like
the whole thing just felt very sort of
like oh like this isn't working and and
by the way
you know i saw you go on twitter and i
know
i know i know guys you can't judge the
world
uh by twitter but there was a lot of
sort of like
general like like what's happening here
like nothing
this doesn't really feel like much of
anything um
which also is sort of interesting
because you know we've got five weeks of
this thing left
and if we just have a lot of sort of oh
it's just it's just
not much then that sort of suppresses
the boat and who does that help
i don't know i don't know but i'd really
be curious to know
for that that sliver in the middle that
sliver in the middle who are you
and and what could move you at this
point that's what i'm saying so when
everybody on the networks
as i said before as whenever one of the
networks is declaring their winners and
losers that that's just
that's just show business right like
that's just oh
my guy won your guy lost like this is
this is wwe
or it's a football game but that's not
really what matters what matters is if
anyone actually moved because of this
and and even that doesn't necessarily
matter because unless they're mailing in
their vote today assuming that mail-in
votes are actually going to make it all
the way
to be counted uh we've still got some
more debates we've still got two more
debates plus a vice presidential debate
plus five weeks where
where absolutely anything could happen
so
my gut feeling is this doesn't move the
dial
much um one of the interesting things
was uh
you know i had to figure out i don't
have cable anymore most people don't
have cable i think everyone's sort of
cutting cutting the cord which is also
one of the reasons why
cable feels so archaic and ridiculous
because more and more people are
ignoring it
so they sort of have to get more
hysterical to kind of keep us paying
attention
uh but i don't have regular television
so we we watched on youtube and we
watched the
the abc feed um that just happened to be
the one i was watching on hulu and and i
guess they're in a partnership with abc
so i was watching george stephanopoulos
before and he had a couple analysts on
now george seven optimus
stephanopoulos remember this and this is
important piece to remember
george stephanopoulos was bill clinton's
i think he was his chief of staff
was he he was either the chief of staff
can we confirm that george
stephanopoulos was he clinton's
chief of staff or or he might have been
a spokesman
it's one or the other but he was in the
i think it was chief of staff but he was
in the
clinton administration and now he's you
know the network anchor for abc news as
if
he can somehow be unbiased in that and
and from the five or ten minutes that i
watched right before it's like all it's
very
obvious it's just very obvious that
all of the people talking about the news
it was being framed
as trump is scary and he's a bad man and
joe biden can come in and he's the good
man
and he must be statesmanlike and and
smart and clean and decent
and talk about a positive future and all
that and it's like well you guys are all
in it for him and again that's what
really it's in a weird way it's like
this election is about
uh it's about the media more than more
than uh trump or biden
and he was the white house
communications director he was not the
chief of staff i
stand corrected ladles and jelly spoons
what do we do here at the reuben report
if i make a mistake we correct it
on air because i won't leave it to
factcheck.org or snopes
to fact check me so i i got one slightly
wrong there
you got me internet and now now the the
youtubers that spend all day long
waiting for dave rubin to get something
wrong there's your clip guys
you can clip it and get a lot of youtube
views i did that for you
you losers uh okay i got about uh about
two minutes left and then i'm jumping
over
uh to the blaze uh the guys over there
are doing a live stream with an
analyst so i will be on with glenn beck
and the team so you can jump over i
believe it's on their youtube channel
or if you're a subscriber to the blaze
tv you can check it out over there so
i'm going to jump over there but anyway
that
that's my summation of the evening there
were no major winners
i thought there was a lot of just sort
of a lot of a lot of
kind of nothingness i think if you're
donald trump you make a statement
tomorrow where he just
kind of comes out he's never going to
say i made a mistake right that's not
trump's style
but he could just come out and do
something on the white supremacy thing
because
that obviously is going to be what the
media runs with or he can wait and clean
it up in the in the next debate
but i think he did stumble on that one
you know biden look biden won't get
called out for anything because he stood
up there and his head didn't explode and
that that's a win for biden because the
that that was the risk by the way of
course that was the risk i tweeted out
this morning i mean the risk was
that that the trump side was getting so
overconfident because there's so many
clips of biden
faltering and stammering and yammering
and the whole thing
that all he had to do was show up and
not completely implode and he clearly
didn't implode so in
a certain way that's a win for him but i
would say
in in real reality
i think we're we're basically looking at
a wash on this thing i don't think it
moved anybody but if it did move you
i would i would absolutely love to know
about it
uh and you can join us at
reubenreport.com that's where i can
actually read comments and communicate
with you guys
and you can post videos and pictures in
the rest of it so it's reubenreport.com
and i would love if you were someone
that was truly moved
tonight or if you know somebody if you
were sitting there
watching this with someone and most
likely they were drunk and then they
said i was
moved by that statement now i know i'm
going to vote for i want to know who
that is
the rest of it's kind of theater and and
it's kind of fun and it's also a little
a little scary and it's a little like
what's going on with this freaking world
um but there will be more debates i
think i think
uh we'll see over the next five or six
weeks which directions
the campaigns go in does trump try to be
a little calmer next time
does biden perhaps reel in some of the
stuff i mean trump it was i'll just say
this last thing what was obvious was
that trump
was trying i think to get by and
agitated because it seems like biden
loses himself when he gets agitated
so it kind of worked that you're dumb
you're a racist
uh you're the worst president in
american history there were a couple
lines like that
and that's where biden then biden
doesn't look very presidential right
when he's doing that
so i think trump's tactic was let me
knock him off the
off his pedestal right at the beginning
so the whole time he's like just trying
to get back and
get his balance and that never kind of
works so they'll go back in
they'll they'll talk to the to the
debate coaches and they'll talk to their
teams and they'll probably try to read
the tea leaves of what the public's
saying
and they'll uh come back with slightly
different strategies next time
but i think there's no winners here
certainly wasn't the american people
tonight
and on that note check me out on the
blaze on their youtube channel right now
or at blazetv.com
and i'll be back in the morning we'll
i'll i'll sleep on it
i'll have a little more whiskey and then
i'll sleep on it and then maybe some
other post-debate
thought will pop in my head you never
know thanks for watching everybody
see you tomorrow